Now in this section we're going to review our camera configuration. Now before we begin we're going to run you through a series of topics to prepare you for your lens calibration.
The first of those is a quick review of our camera configuration. Now your camera configuration is going to be different than what we have but here at the latte stage we actually use a black magic Ursa Mini.
We also have a Zeiss 25mm compact prime 3 lens and for reference we use Atomos Shogun. We have that sitting on a Leibach LX10 tripod and we also have the optional ProAIM Swift Dolly if we want to use Dolly moves.
We connect all of that through our AJA key Pro Ultra 12G recorder using also the AJA Kona 5 as our master clock but that's optional.
Now for our optical tracking system we use OptiTrackMotive and we use the 209 Groups tracking mine as our active tracking system.
On top of that we have the option of the Epic Games Sputnik created by Kevin Cushing using 3D printed tools and passive markers.
Now we also want to review the media profile implementation from our previous classes. What is the media profile used for? Well the media profile is a required asset that the lens file uses to locate the video source used by Composure to overlay our CG elements in Unreal Engine inside the lens file asset editor that we use for calibration.
Note your media profile proxies configuration will automatically detect the number of sources available in your configuration. However you don't have to use or configure for both or more of them if you have multiples. Just configure for the profile that you're going to be using.
In this case we have two sources but we only calibrated for one profile.
That's it for this section. In our next section we're going to go ahead and take a look at some of our other tracking solutions and other options.